12 dicembre al porto malpensa 8 45 del
mattino
stiamo per imbarcare partenza per mosca
[Musica]
siamo curiosissimi di uscire da questa
strada qui a sentire il freddo dimostra
io pensavo peggio dai
[Musica]
qui la nostra stanza guardate che
meraviglia su persone e sulla scrivania
ci sono due colpacci di e questi due
portachiavi con le matrioske e quella è
la view non si vede perché c'è il
riflesso ma lì c'è la piazza rossa che
siamo proprio in centro centro c'è
allora prima sera ha deciso di tagliare
i capelli
mi piace questo nuovo look
niente se una parrucca però il ghiaccio
ero a cena in un ristorante italiano che
si chiama sartoria lamberti devo dire
impressi mi stai facendo male
lo senti non sia un amante dei sanitari
ha detto oggi primo giorno di tour di
mosca io sono entrata nel personaggio
salvo pure
[Musica]
modalità da inizia attivata mi presento
la nostra guida per oggi la signora
natalia e purissimo parla ovviamente
inglese con l'accento russe
[Musica]
io
oggi pranzo qui siamo al white rabbit
che un ristorante molto famoso che a
mosca
guardate che gli sta tutto addobbato per
natale si vede tutta la città
ora stiamo per iniziare a mangiare ci
stanno facendo fare queste cose
praticamente già mettono qualche goccia
di vodka nelle mani di questi vedete che
ammette la volta delle mani adesso
bisogna fare gare e poi annusare allora
questo è l'antipasto che appunto pane
tipico miniero con sopra un lardo cotto
anche sono abbastanza scioccata to
minimo 16 buono non si capisce perché mi
sto riprendendo
spegnendo e non potete capire le
emozioni ragazzi sono davanti al teatro
bol'soj per tutti i ballerini che io
sono stata ballerina anticipa è
un'emozione
eccoci dentro guardate che meraviglia
[Musica]
allora ragazzi siamo nella famosissima
piazza rossa reds perdita per dio
siamo arrivati diciamo che non faceva
freddo ma era ieri oggi è diverso
pure le campane
questa sera a cena da puskin che un
fortissimo il ristorante quindi mosca
dove ovviamente cucinano piatti tipici
ore 20
vinceremo questo caso
è un po paura sì faremo
secondo giorno ma ieri comunque erano
molto coperti ma abbiamo sentito un po
di freddo quindi oggi siamo coperti
ancora di più io tipo sei mani addosso
e ho aggiunto il colbacco ci dovremo
girare un po la città quindi saremo
molto fuori quindi c'è però per forza
coprirci ostriche champagne viene giù
una valanga striscio lo skipass
settimana bianca allora ricapitoliamo un
attimo quanti strate abbiamo addosso io
dire quanta colla pur con l'aldilà na
volta con la termico e un protocollo con
il file dentro poi sopra o un body di
cashmere sopra la maglietta termica
sopra ancora un collo alto bastato
sentire sopra ancora un maggiore bello
spesso e poi la giacca se oggi siamo
venuti a visitare la gelateria 50 del
mondo
e ci troviamo
glielo danno di molti
allora la situazione è questa
freddo salvatore sembra un anno è uscito
dal milan si parli di volumi salgono
allora oggi abbiamo pranzato qui si
chiama tempo
ed è un
come forse un centro commerciale con il
posto dei negozi tutti dei vari
ristorantini e bar ognuno con delle
specialità diverse
visitiamo il museo aerospaziale e
dell'aviazione di mosca le ragazze
quando hanno freddo quali io io quando
esco d'inverno stessa faccia
stasera siamo al ristorante o brand è
molto carino che si mangia pure molto
bene questo è evidente e purè di patate
scusate avrò mangiato quindi non è
bellissimo vedere però alcune di patate
con una sorta di spezzatino e queste
sembrano delle chips la patatina
momento molto buono salvo invece cosa è
già finito ci hanno fatti conoscere
della videocamera ragazze ultimo giorno
purtroppo terzo giorno si facciamo una
visita al museo puskin e
e niente sono bionda
sono grandissime ad ora
ragazzi siamo per iniziare una lezione
di cucina pronti carichi
allora ci dobbiamo preparare i beni che
sono decreti per apparire quasi pronto
mai roma
ci siamo qui c'è un poco armi pensavo
allora situazione attuale nel bel mezzo
del spa della mente di una crepa mi sono
bruciata
quindi ho smesso di fare le robe però
continuato salgo per me adesso devo
permette di mangiare tutte le crepe e
abbiamo fatto anche dei ravioli con
dentro carne cipolla aglio
non so se n'era stretti
dopo una lezione di cucina siamo volati
in aeroporto si torna a casa sono stati
pochi giorni molto intensi speriamo
tantissimo se vi sia piaciuto questo
blog
e mi metterò magari in descrizione tutti
posti che abbiamo visitato e ristoranti
che siano stati così siri capiterà mai
di venire qui troverete tutte le
formazioni e saper miri più seguite
visit moscow vi lascio qual nome del
profilo contro chi insomma alte
corsichesi mosca davos che tutto in
saluto all in e allo studio
[Musica]